the title of this presentation is how to
program and it's a rumination on a word
workflow two part word work being what
programs are their structure and
behavior flow being how we program our
thoughts and actions and when I look
back on my experience learning as a
computer science student he taught me
things like data structures and P versus
NP and big-oh analysis and cryptography
and not very much about how to think or
how to work and boot schools nowadays
are you know actually analogous even
though they're more market practical
skills like web standards and system
tooling and languages and frameworks not
so much how to think through problems
and solve stuff and really write code
and you might think that's the job of
thought leaders because the word thought
is right there but really thought
leaders when they're talking about
design patterns or solid principles even
when they talk about agile and
test-driven development
those are nice because they describe
work activities but it's pretty discreet
and mostly about how people in Iraq not
so much how to think through things so
it's reasonable to ask you know when do
we actually learn flow as programmers
who teaches us how to think and if
you're lucky you know ten years into
your career you'll stumble upon or
somebody will show you you know the only
productivity tip that any of us have
ever been taught where you work for 20
minutes and even take a three minute
break it's really awesome but honestly
it kind of feels like you put ten years
a hard service in to to get a you know
four dollar plastic pin it's kind of
insulting that that's the best that we
have to offer so sure somehow we all
learn what programs are but I hazard a
guess that most of us nobody ever really
taught us how to program look no further
than a Google search how to program and
you get a whole bunch of terrible
results starting with the traditional
way of teaching people how to program
you start with nothing and then some of
you shows you a completely finished
example the finished product what the
program should be and then as for
connecting it it's a good luck have fun
and every single computer science
assignment that I had in college you
know really resembled the how to draw
a little comic where you start with two
circles and they don't draw the rest of
the owl and I spend entire weekends
cooped up in a lab trying to figure out
you know we're staring at a blank end
there no idea how to write code and it
was that moment but I realized that
programming is almost a philosophical
activity that happens mostly in our
heads
of course we've now innovated quite a
lot in programmer education since I was
in college now now we instead of just
one big finished example we've broken it
up into two or three steps over the
course of a book or a screencast but
very rarely does the prose or the
explanation actually explain the
thinking of how to make that thing more
real it's might take years before you're
able to imitate you know even an example
application from a book but that were an
invitation stands out because I think
that most of us are just imitating other
programmers we see somebody successful
or well-known and we just try to do
things like they seem to be doing things
and that's how we kind of learn and get
by you can see that this is endemic in
our society as programmers because we're
really bad at how questions if I ask how
do I know when to create a new method
when should I break this thing up into
more than one thing you know you get
really unsophisticated responses like
methods should be about three lines long
[Laughter]
and when my wife she likes telling her
story when she was in first grade Becky
she was told by a teacher that sentences
were two lines long and so then
dutifully for the next several years
until she was corrected he just stamped
a period at the end of every other and
that's funny because she's not an adult
and yet here we are with these
unsophisticated ideas like and I think
she'd be about three lines long and no
ability to communicate above and beyond
that but let's say in spite of all of
this somehow you write a really good
program one day and you're really proud
of it and really happy and I ask you
okay so what actions were productive or
unproductive that led you to that point
or what thoughts led you there which
which thought processes were successful
or unsuccessful would you be able to
answer those questions or not most of us
wouldn't be able to and it leads to
rampant insecurity from how we educate
programmers to the work that we do to
the colleagues that we keep in the
overall industry now 99% of the work
that I've done as a professional
programmer could be boiled down as a
businessperson trying to get a
spreadsheet onto the Internet
and yet it's taken me ten years or so to
even become a merely competent
programmer and that's clearly
something's wrong and how we teach
people to program and this industry is
60 or 70 years old but we're still
searching for silver bullets we always
are externalizing the problem and hoping
the next language or framework or
library or process is going to suddenly
make programming explicable and it never
works out and think about that situation
you know where everyone's either making
stuff up as they go or pretending they
understand it who's gonna succeed in
that environment it's genuinely
brilliant people and people with the
overconfidence of having been told that
they're brilliant their whole lives so
imagine that you don't look like other
programmers and you walk into a room and
you lack that privilege of having been
told that you're brilliant by society
this is a terrifying line of work to
walk into because no one can actually
explain how to program and I think that
if you want to make programming a more
diverse and inclusive industry we really
need to solve this
[Applause]
and it's obvious that the industry has
no idea how software works because
they're constantly analogizing it to
literally any other industry like
construction or like design or
manufacturing and because of that they
control the handful of things that they
do understand like estimates and when
people work and where they work instead
of like the true none of it which is
like how we think as software developers
and how we solve problems so how do we
fix it
well fortunately yesterday at the
keynote DHH offered us one solution but
I'm gonna talk about a different one I'm
gonna talk about feedback loops because
programmers through compilation and
through testing we're used to
establishing feedback loops to make
forward progress and we can do the same
things inside of our heads improving as
developers we're gonna practice this
today by reflecting on the actions we
take and whether you're successful or
not and how to improve our actions you
can do the same thing for feelings and
actually reflect on your emotional state
so you can reinforce positive emotions
or mitigate negative ones and spoiler
alert you can actually think about
thinking and produce better thought
processes that turn out to be more
productive this is really the path to
program or enlightenment but I realize
that we're starting from scratch here we
got a walk before we can run and ask
yourself what do we do with teams that
are so kind of emotionally immature they
struggle to even talk about feelings
well we handle crappy personality tests
like the myers-briggs Type Indicator
if you're not familiar with the
myers-briggs just know that it's the
worst type system
the reason we rag on it is because it
puts people into these silly buckets
like ENTJ and isfp and the implication
is that there's only 16 types of people
out there but we know that that's
there's much much more but when you're
starting from 0 16 starts sounding
pretty good so that's why today I'm
pleased to announce the Searls Briggs
Type Indicator and instead of
pontificating to you today about how to
program and dictating that this is the
magical way this is the Silver Bullet
instead I'm just gonna humbly take my
own test show you how I feel and my
inclinations in my personality and what
I've done over the course of my career
to reflect and improve and result in
better outcomes as a programmer to do
that we need an example feature so let's
make one up like I mentioned I work at a
company test double and we have always
been a distributed company but we're
still learning that that does not mean
evenly distributed so if you've got a
flat organization you might think that
there's all these spontaneous
relationships that form but of course
that's not accurate we all have our
assigned pairs and we all have flown
home to an account manager our org chart
looks like one of those 1980s suction
COBOL things but there's nothing wrong
with that per se unless like two people
on the team both really want to learn
Elm but there's nothing systemically
that's gonna get those two people
talking together necessarily so somebody
raised the idea why don't we have
virtual coffee dates on the team and
just randomly assign people to talk to
people who talk to each other that
otherwise wouldn't be it's actually an
expression for math though it's called a
handshake problem which which just
calculates the number of potential
relationships of any group of people and
you see that there's just tons of them
and so what the system should do is just
send an email every week to pair up
people who might not otherwise be
talking to one another and tell them go
spend 15 minutes on this Google hangout
URL and chat about something doesn't
have to be about work and so we're gonna
put my test to the test and build this
future together this morning as a group
and the first bucket that I'm gonna put
us in is sensitive versus fearless and
the first question is I prefer hearing
all requirements upfront even if I can't
tackle them all right away I strongly
disagree with that I get overwhelmed
relieved
to adding to a long function feels like
more code just won't fit absolutely I
once I had a certain amount of
complexity I can't imagine adding
another case three I look forward to
being assigned to new projects and teams
no way new projects give me night sweats
for I often feel paralyzed while staring
at a blank editor screen yeah I already
admitted to that does that make me
sensitive or fearless pretty obvious in
this case I'm sensitive a big part of
being sensitive is that I get
overwhelmed easily so think about this
feature and all I've got to do you know
create pairs great that's not so hard
but I do have to go and send the email
and I also have to look up all these
people from a database but I got to be
careful not to repeat so I got to
randomize the pairings and I gotta not
repeat week to week either which means I
also have to persist them there's a lot
of work so I I don't want to think about
all that I just want to focus on the
core problem so my inclination is like
just do that put a unit around it think
hard about the problem I can do my
little test-driven development thing I'm
feeling really good about that unit of
code so then I go to the controller
that's gonna call it and I realize that
the method signature doesn't quite line
up or somebody else might say hey this
this unit you just made is doing all
this extra redundant work that's
actually handled elsewhere my
inclination was to overcome that
paralysis that I felt and find some
productivity by just putting on blinders
and I fell into that rabbit hole often
enough that I had to think and reflect
and actually I've inverted how I work as
a programmer so what I just showed you
is often called bottom-up programming
but now I practice top-down it looks
better for me
you might also call it outside in where
I think from the perspective of the
controller at the top level entry point
and I start there and I asked what do I
need
why me something to create these pairs
and when your brain is focused that way
the caller knows exactly what inputs are
available what output it's gonna want is
also a way that like minimize like waste
because it has the broader context in
terms of you know life what guard
clauses need to be inserted or can be
omitted the other aspect of being
sensitive is that I'm really afraid of
failure and when you work outside in you
do have to juggle all these different
concerns at once which can again be
overwhelming and so
what I try to do is just rush into
solving it like my inclination is just
today open up an editor and prove that I
can write this code so I start with a
module and I make a method I go and load
up a bunch of users I loop over them I
skip anyone who's already had their hand
shaken otherwise I'll go and add a tuple
of like a you know represent the pairing
and they'll go and slam it through some
mailer and now I feel really good
because I just proved I could do it and
someone will remind me you remember got
to randomize it and you don't want to
leave out the 15th person every week and
you've also got to prevent repeats from
happening week to week and now I'm
terrified because I can this is already
really dense I don't know how I'm gonna
make it more complicated and I am very
familiar with this corner of the room as
a result so I keep paying myself into
this corner and the root causes fear I'm
way to failing I'm afraid of big things
that I don't know how to break down so
my solution is avoid that fear by
breaking things down in a systematized
way give myself some help and I've been
practicing over the last few years
iterating on an approach to test-driven
development that I call a discovery
testing and it's really an upper in
breaking big scary problems into smaller
more manageable ones
it works with I start with just a test
of that top level thing so I write a
single test case I invoke the thing and
then I ask myself a crucial question
what's the code that I wish I had that I
could defer and hand this work out to
well something to find these hands
something returning Satan's hand
something to mail them and then persist
them then I use my testable library
which in Ruby is gimme so it treats
these four fake things and I set up a
stubbing so I say hey when finds hands
is called it gets you have this thing to
symbolize the hands and if I pass that
to the thing that you tell me is the
shakes
another stubbing will give me B as Pam
shakes this is all the tests said if I
need to be able to actually assert that
I mail out all those handshakes and then
I persist them now this is an
unusual-looking test to a lot of you I'm
sure but what it does is it perfectly
specifies the behavior of that top level
unit and so I get this test to pass and
I never have to worry about that top
level again in fact if you list out all
the files that shake out from just
getting that Tusker pass now I have a
pretty clear you know work cut out for
me I know exactly what I mean
do I can start making forward progress
so I start off with a big scary thing
but as I build that test I identify the
units that I would need to actually
carve out the work and instead of one
big scary thing I now have four more
digestible problems then I can focus on
and if any of them are scary I know have
in my back pocket a tool that I can use
to like reduce and break things up even
further the second bucket I'm going to
talk about is inventive versus aesthetic
so there's some quiz questions to
determine my my type question one it's
more important to build the right thing
than to build the thing right yeah these
are both important but I'm more
implementation focused question two I
love experimenting with new tools
frameworks and build systems not at all
like I do spend a lot of my time in
open-source here but it's expressly so I
don't have to worry about it at work
question three I strive to write
visually appealing code down to syntax
and symmetry absolutely I don't know why
but I really like pretty symmetrical
code question four it's boring when all
the code in a project is structured
similarly I disagree i really like
consistency in code so you gotta make me
inventive or aesthetic well I think it
makes me a little aesthetic and one part
of being ascetic as I have refined
tastes now the problem with taste is
that nobody knows what it is until
somebody on your team says you know what
I'd prefer a 300 line function to all
these well named little small units that
you keep creating and then my face looks
like this
that's taste
there's a wide members develop taste
well it's obvious when you're staring at
a blank on your screen there are
infinitely many ways to solve any given
problem we need something to constrain
ourselves some some patterns to follow
to just not be stuck in analysis
paralysis forever and that's why I think
that prose is a much better analogy to
writing software than construction is in
fact I think of programming is just
communication to the next developer
who's gonna pick it up and it's just
hard because it has to happen through
this filter that's just formal enough
for an interpreter or a compiler to
understand and so what I hear this
feedback I reflect and I take it to meet
it as I think that maybe I'm writing
code that's meant to be read by myself
as opposed to another human because the
other developer they're not in the room
so I tend to write code that I think
that I would want to read and this leads
to self centered design so if I just
wrote a book on design patterns I'm
gonna create a bunch of units like
services and factories and repositories
and I'm gonna feel really brilliant
having done all this but then somebody
else can list out all of the files I
just created a one big listing from
their perspective it's gonna be
impenetrably complex it's a forest of
all these objects no idea how things are
gonna work and so now when I hear that
critique they've got a pretty good point
and I found this happen on team after
team and what I realize is I got to
start working differently to make my
code more discoverable and approachable
for other developers and now I do things
much differently it started with
realizing programs are directed graphs
so all of these units are really kind of
nodes in this graph and all of the edges
or vertices are function calls
so then locator calls the service which
calls this repository which causes
mapper which instantiates Hands service
also calls this factory which calls that
thing in that thing and we already can
we think of programs this way we have
some taste we have some constraining
principles that we share like for
instance if this repository where it
called this service we would all wait a
second you know that's a that's a
dependency cycle we'd realize there's a
risk of a infinite recursion or like you
know a stack overflow there and so most
of the programs that we write as
developers try to be a cyclic diagraphs
and remember Mike
here is just to prove that I'm right I
want to tell this person no small units
is better than 300 lines objectively and
to do that I thought maybe there's a
liberating constraint maybe if I refine
my tastes further I can solve this
problem and and where I landed was I
want to express all of my features not
as just general grasp but as trees
because I tree is just a special subtype
of a graph you can take this exact same
menagerie of units and organize it in a
tree shape where you have your value
objects on the left and the function
future behavior on the right and now if
it's true that I have any need listing
direction it stands out in a tree
because it's just got one child so that
service locator yeah I can probably get
rid of that and if somebody asks you
know it's been what they're looking for
is how to compare two hands they can
search the tree much more easily and
quickly than just a gigantic directory
of files and and find what they're
looking for so it's more discoverable
the other aspect of my aesthetic is I'm
a minimalist so when you look at our app
you see it's a car it drives you think
about what its function is and why it
exists when I look at our app all I see
is the clutter and the mess and as a
minimalist my productivity goes up when
things are tidy and symmetrical and
terse and it goes down when things are
cluttered or inconsistent and what the
software is supposed to be doing is it's
essential complexity everything it
actually does is it's incidental
complexity the other stuff think of
everything that goes into writing a
program you're writing deploy tooling
and app config and dependencies and
framework appeasement then of course
there's whatever the Apple is supposed
to do there's style rules continuous
integration build systems and then of
course unnecessary stuff as a minimalist
I'm the person on the project who's
always chiseling away to try to minimize
the amount of incidental complexity in
the system and trying to maximize the
time that the team spends on whatever is
really important that means I'm always
tweaking my code style like maybe I'd
start writing future behavior inside of
my model objects but then separate them
out into separate units but then maybe
make them callable is what maybe
ultimately landed module methods these
are all fine you can debate the finer
points by the end of the day
really six of one half a dozen the other
kinds of arguments and they represent a
sort of trap because earlier I said like
style of rules debating style is a type
of incidental complexity because style
is subjective and so it changes around
arbitrarily and arbitrary decisions
breed inconsistency and oh it turns out
that inconsistency is another form of
incidental complexity and so oops
because I thought Monday I organized
code this way and on Tuesday this way
and Wednesday that way and then by
Thursday I've decided this is the best
way to organize code everyone's gonna
get mad at me because I just littered
thirty-six custom little Styles all
throughout the system so my temptation
to continuously be improving stuff
actually breeds inconsistency and
creates bigger messes elsewhere so I
reflected on how I think what would
happen is I chased the local
optimization at the expense of like the
global optimization of what's best for
the overall project and I had to learn
to avoid miss oscillation in my design
and it really required me to just
realize I'd spend the entire project
spinning my tires and so instead I
decided I need to lock in these
decisions and say we're just gonna do
things this style whether or not it's
better or worse it doesn't matter so we
can try to carve out time to be
productive and as I got better at that
at flexing that muscle I can recognize
where I'm spinning my wheels earlier and
spend more of my time being productive
it was a way for me to both be
minimalist but also really consistent in
my applications even when it meant
hewing really strongly to arbitrary
decisions of things that didn't really
matter and when you do that especially
with your incidental complexity it
brings the essential complexity into
sharper relief so you can all as a team
really just focus much spend more time
on what your app really needs to do the
third bucket is naive versus leery
question one publishing metrics like a
code coverage is always a good idea and
I think radical transparency often
backfires question two writing good
commit messages today will pay off in
the future secret I don't actually read
commit messages
three software teams will make smarter
use of time under pressure disagree I
think pressure kills cognition for
software is generally improving over
time and we are not doomed past so does
that make me naive or leery I'm starting
to realize this is a pretty obvious test
in my case I'm weary it all starts with
my distrust of all of you because most
teams operate in a pressure cooker
they're under pressure to get as much
stuff done as fast as possible and as a
result their brains turn off and it you
know results in really really bad
outcomes in fact it's not very fair to
pressure-cook nurse because pressure
cookers serve a useful purpose so I'll
find another analogy where we're just
being squeezed for all of the Ruby and
JavaScript that we're worth and again
not being creative not resulting in good
code one person on teams I don't trust
is I don't trust product owners I love
them but I don't trust them back in the
waterfall days you know product owner
would be able to specify 300 bullet
points of everything that they ever
wanted and then force them upon us and
we'd say hey this is awful but you know
in a way at least it was honest they got
to articulate everything that they
wanted upfront it was just us who didn't
know how to handle that much complexity
scrum and agile stuff kind of gave us a
little bit of a backbone and we said no
sir you only get one index card at a
time and in fact that's gonna be 20
points and I made up what points mean so
naturally then it becomes a debate of no
I think it's five points and any system
can be gained and really savvy product
owners I know are really good at this
like oh you know this is not that
complex it's just a little cartoon whale
you guys can do that right you have time
and we'll say oh yeah sure we can do
that and then we realize it's much more
complex than we really thought and by
then they're out to lunch and we're left
holding the bag so I don't trust product
owners for someone I trust even less
than front
versus other developers and it's because
of a feature we neglect to realize a
very basic fact our brains can only hold
so much stuff in them at once and so I
think the developers have this bias
toward sizing features to just whatever
number of things they can hold in their
head in time and naturally the
conclusion that we draw about how big
our objects and methods should be is the
same size because then in that way we
can just put all the things in one place
it seems like this simple solution but
then a month passes and somebody says
hey you need to add a couple additional
aspects to this feature you know it has
to do this and this as well well that
means that the other stuff like I'm
brain is finite we can't you know keep
it all in our heads at once anymore but
units we can make files as long as we
want so we just even though we're
incurring a paging cost we can slam in
those additional attributes to the
feature but it creates a blind spot for
us where you know now that we're not
thinking about the the persistence you
know bugs can creep in through that door
and if you work this way a year passes
and pretty soon your units are just as
gigantic and they look like this and
they're riddled with bugs and normally
they four hundred is the day that I get
a phone call saying hey can you help
improve our tests of course this isn't a
testing problem right it's like a
complexity management problem and it's
hard for me when I see this cycle repeat
over and over again to let that distrust
kind of like grow into cynicism and
that's not good and in fact if I'm
empathetic I realize that at the root of
this industry all of us really struggle
to predict how complexity is going to
change and to guess the complexity of
stuff and I do it too and so what I want
to do is is is change the question and
instead focus on how to prepare myself
and other people for an inevitable
increase of complexity because I'm any
maintaining system almost any of them
they're gonna complexity is gonna go up
over time it's just a matter of what
that graph looks like
and so like Pascal I made up sources
wager in my head we're sure complexity
might remain constant or it might go up
and yeah we could keep writing these
brain sized units or much smaller ones
and the complexity doesn't change you
know no harm no foul it doesn't really
matter how
we factor our code what if it goes up we
have a lot of evidence that these larger
units cause problems and the nice thing
about small ones is they can actually
accommodate some additional complexity
without too much pain that's why I'm day
one of every feature I break things up
into any bitty tiny units to the point
where people criticize me and you know
if you think that my units are too small
don't worry because I trust that you're
gonna go and make them bigger later
it'll work out it's a great way if you
struggle with like trying to make follow
the single responsibility principle I
have every object do one thing this
makes it really really easy in fact this
is what the tree of functionality kind
of shipped out as in this example and
every single unit serves exactly one
purpose and they all follow one of three
roles that I've kind of observed over
the years of practicing this the parent
nodes are delegator objects they don't
really have any logic or branching maybe
just like one if condition or something
they mostly just break up the work and
hand it off to other things and the way
that I happen to do that is I use this
test-driven design where I used Eskimos
to identify and think of once you know
what's the code I wish I had that they
would actually do the real work what you
want to try to maximize is these leaf
nodes so this is where the core logic of
the application is it takes inputs and
transforms into some kind of output you
know these are pure functions and you
don't need test doubles you just are
actually testing real logic these are
the kinds of unit tests that everyone
likes to write and it's sort of like
functional programming for people who
don't want to think too hard about
functional programming it makes it very
accessible because you can still do it
and you know Ruby you don't have to
change languages or something on the
left are my values and value objects
they just wrap a little bit of data
maybe they just hold on to a hash or an
array and the methods on them are only
allowed to elucidate in the data and
answer questions about the data as
opposed to doing feature work they're
not there to actually build features
instead I think of them as the sludge
that flows through the pipes of my
feature occurred they're the types in
those method signatures and even if all
of us abstraction doesn't ultimately pay
off and even if that feature doesn't
change a lot in the future in the very
worst case I've got a very discoverable
system of carefully named thing
that are obvious and small and
comprehensible so it's not the worst
outcome in the world the third aspect
here is that I distrust myself even more
than all of you it's because I worry
about the future and even though I'm not
super confident in today in these skills
I'm even more worried that my future
self won't be able to program either for
some reason and so when I'm writing a
feature somebody says build this thing
I'll think about how to build it and
then I'll build kind of a message in a
bottle for myself in the form of better
tests and documentation and commit
messages things to try to help and my
future self who's wearing sunglasses is
told to change that feature he gives
really frustrated because what those
tests mean is now he's got a bunch of
other stuff to do every time he wants to
make a change and my future self would
much rather just start fresh and be able
to write new code and so I kept trying
to do myself favors by writing a lot of
extra tests and adding in all this
quality at the beginning but it would
actually tie my hands and so I had to
reflect how do I bake quality into my
applications without creating an undue
burden for my future self and so I
started working a little bit differently
because if this is our tree of
functionality and our manager comes in
and says new requirement like thanks to
some HR Fiasco all handshakes have to
happen between three people the
traditional way to solve this is to
carefully read the existing code add
remove change tests change the code and
then trying to make a small of a mess as
possible and I say small mess because
any time the purpose of a piece of code
has many two things whenever we change a
unit it kind of carries with it
technical debt it confuses the story of
why it existed because it's changed over
time so instead I've been trying to make
my code disposable uh what that means is
that when I look at this tree I search
for all of the affected units by the
changes these are two units they're
gonna change and so then I find the
smallest subtree that encapsulates that
change and so there it is right there
and then I do something unusual I blow
it all up
I just knock it out because I trust that
my future self is gonna be able to see
that top level thing and understand what
the contract
is so there he is he's gonna drive out a
new solution and as opposed to just
changing these old units that implement
in Viet logic the old way and thus rack
up technical debt today I trust me to
drive out a new solution and in fact the
future US is gonna have more experience
than present-day us they'll probably
have a better understanding of the
business they'll be able to write better
units in the future than a week ever
could hope to you today so this is a
healthy way to work it does mean that I
try not to reuse code too much in my
future code because any code reuse like
if you have a mention that's called in
nine places it's just really hard to
change that method cuz you have to
consider nine different places callers
and what they need it's also really hard
to throw it away and replace it so I try
not to reuse too much code and it also
forced me to let go of this idea that
maintainable code has to live forever in
fact you know is as opposed to that this
incremental rewrite in the small as part
of your process is a way to pay
technical debt you know without saving a
rainy day fund for when you finally get
to refactor and in doing that I actually
made myself happier because future me
does not want his job to be you know
fixing all of Justin's old jakey tests
every time that he changes something
wants to be able to write code for a
living and so this is this process by
making like you know death a part of
life while we're working through
features is a great way to keep your
team's happy I found the last bucket
here is economical versus thorough the
question one better to ship code quickly
than wait until everything is tested and
I feel like I just need bailing out
water in that case two design principles
are useful but most teams waste too much
time on them it's possible for sure but
few teams are at risk of this three most
teams lack of sufficient understanding
of their dependencies absolutely you
know 90% of us have no clue how most of
our code works in our applications and
four it's okay for everyone on the team
to maintain separate coding styles I
actually strongly disagree because this
means two siloed development it's kind
of like a Conway's law of style so does
that make any economical or thorough
well of course it makes me thorough some
of you are noticing that this spells
salt
that's because when you make up the quiz
you can make it spell whatever you want
it's gonna surprise a few of you to
learn today a confession to make I'm a
bit of a control freak and that means
I'm dubious of free stuff so when you
see a sign that says free puppies all I
read is extra work and another thing in
our industry that makes me think extra
work is open source and so just keep
that in your head next time you're on
you know asking for free labor from an
open-source maintainer imagine you're
yelling at a puppy instead because who
yells at puppy's jerk and open source
isn't free because just like puppies we
have to learn how to use it or if they
learn how it's changing and follow it
and and and it's not just this panacea
that we can pull off the internet and
instead of having to build stuff
ourselves and if that open source has a
bug you know in theory sure we can fix
it ourselves but in practice we're not
going to understand all that stuff we're
probably gonna have to rely on a
maintainer or an expert to come and fix
it later
finally like if we have you know like
let's say that this is our graph of
objects and it's all very consistent
everywhere and we slam in some third
party API that's gonna create a certain
amount of friction and pain because it's
not going to look like all of our other
objects in fact third party dependencies
have this really nasty habit of leaking
references all over our code base which
makes it really hard to change or
replace or upgrade those third-party
dependencies over time so my temptation
of all these negative things about open
source and puppies instant well I don't
have a puppy first of all again much to
my wife Becky use consternation but - I
try to like avoid using open source and
that's what my gut tells me to do but
that's increasingly untenable these days
because I'd be reinventing wheels
constantly so I had to change how I
thought about open source instead -
maybe protecting myself from its blast
radius as opposed to avoiding it
entirely and the way that I do that is I
write wrappers of all the third-party
code that I write in fact we already
have one up on this tree it's that finds
Hands unit on the left so there's a
wrapper object that starts it's just a
well named delegator it's a no op it
doesn't do anything interesting but it
comes to encode all of our understanding
of that dependency it is the carpet
under which we sweep all of the stuff
that we have to do to make that third
party dependency happy and I integration
test it but only in proportion to how
suspicious I am of it breaking otherwise
I trust that in itself is tested well
and it might feel like a needless new
direction but I need you to trust me
that it's not of course if this is where
we're calling finds hands in our in our
top-level code and I just told you not
to trust other developers so you don't
trust me you assume that like that
wrapper is unnecessary let's say and
instead of using that call we're just
gonna call user dot all instead that way
it's much more direct we got rid of that
needless indirection
which means we have a bigger test so
this is our original test we can get rid
of that fake finder and instead have an
array of real users that we create in
the database of course validation failed
so now I have to add like a birthday
some other arbitrary thing to make this
work but I can also get rid of the
stubbing here and pass real users into
the other stubbing and yeah I gotta make
an integration test as opposed to a unit
test and ask yourself now what did we
just do because the value of this test
used to be crystal-clear its purpose was
to break the work up in the floor clear
responsibilities and now what is it it's
an it's calling through to the database
so it's making sure that the thing works
but only when 3/4 and the code paths are
fake like that doesn't seem right that
seems wrong to me and it's really
becomes obviously wrong when this
becomes more complex because if we add a
couple scopes like only search for
full-time and active employees then our
test is needs nothing anymore because
those scopes are like branches so now we
need two or three test cases to cover
everything and now it's abundantly
obvious that we sliced things wrong so
when I hear teams complaining you have
too many instructions or too many
objects typically the thing that's it's
not wrong it's something you're making
not in too many abstractions and of no
abstraction is somehow better it's that
you're probably mixing the levels of
abstraction in your system because life
with wrappers is much easier if I look
at that same thing and dive into what
that record looks like yes I'm day one
it looks like a needless indirection but
I'm day two when it gives more context
there is a it's easy to write a test for
this there's a place for that complexity
to go and over time you know it might
become a little bit more complicated as
distance yourself further here with like
a transformer to a type that you own as
opposed to you know an active record
user so let's say our boss comes in and
says we're gonna change from active
record to the sequel gem traditionally
this would really panic everyone in the
room because if it had a billion
references to active record all over
your system but when you're writing
rappers carefully on your third party
dependencies you're actually prevent
from preparing for yourself an adapter
interface that's minimal and specifies
exactly how you use that dependency so
you can even answer questions like would
it be possible to switch to this third
party thing and if you did you can
create an alternate implementation and
run both in parallel for a while it's a
much much better way to work and when I
found those it's a way to maintain you
still have all that convenience of open
source and sucking in these useful
libraries while maintaining control over
how you work so when you're is
introspective about this stuff as I am
you run the risk of explaining the
universe through yourself in fact if you
ask anyone who's ever worked on a
project with me what my favorite way to
write code is it's my way and I'll fight
you for it so my inclination is just
work really hard to convince you all
that my way is best and I'd love to say
that that's an altruistic thing and I
want you all to be better programmers
but it's not it's selfish what it really
is is I'm afraid I'm gonna have a
manager someday tell me that I can't
write code my favorite way anymore and
when I reflect on that even if I were to
come up with the perfect way to write
code and hand it to you I run the risk
of robbing you of that same autonomy so
that wouldn't be good either
and so that's why I'm getting out in the
silver bullet business so even though I
talked a lot today about how I program
I'm not here to sell you on that I mean
I hope you find some of it useful but
what I really am here to sell you on is
the idea of pausing and introspecting
about how you act feel and think while
you're programming so that it becomes
more explicable to you and then you can
articulate it to other people it
and Cheryl you might ask yourself hey if
we all start thought leading ourselves
won't I just create chaos on our teams
and I think that's actually a valid
concern so let's spend a minute to talk
about that because earlier I said if you
lock down all those arbitrary decisions
up front you can spend more time being
productive that's true individually but
it's also true as teams and that's why
when you have disagreements with other
people on teams you should aggressively
pull those forward because the earlier
you have that discussion and say okay
you know we'll use these semicolons we
will follow this style if you can agree
to that stuff early and lock it and
you'll as a team be more productive and
in fact if you look at the average team
remember what I said earlier we're all
just imitating other programmers so most
teams actually like the idea of
normalizing in fact some of them like it
too much where if you have a creative
idea of doing things differently no I
don't want to rock the boat you know I
don't want to like you know do my own
thing off here or go off the reservation
quote-unquote so instead we tend to just
gravitate towards the lowest common
denominator a lot of teams and that's
not good but that's not you anymore
right because after today you're going
to be thinking about how the actions you
take could be improved your feelings
improving your thought processes and I'm
your next team when you draw in a team
of all enlightened Hugh Jackman's some
of whom will be salt and some of whom
will be fine which is literally what the
other for trade spell and some will be
sale and some of these fault when you
look at this team yeah sure they all in
very strongly held opinions that of
different ways of doing things but the
one thing they have in common is when
they're approached with a new idea they
have a system for testing it and
figuring out whether they do adopt or
reject it so they're not afraid of
trying new things and that's why I think
that really introspecting developers
rather when they're on a team they might
just look like they're talking at the
whiteboard all day but they can actually
have a multiplicative impact on each
other as they grow and that's really my
dream today is that if we can as an
industry normalize the concept of
metacognition and as self-improvement so
that we can explain how to program this
whole place might start making a whole
lot more sense
and that is how the program so I
appreciate your time here today if
you're looking for a company to work
with that's going to support you on this
kind of journey I hope you'd consider
checking us out that's our page explain
what it's like to work with us a test
double and if you're a company that like
is looking for additional developers on
your team I hope you consider working
with us we join other teams just as
additional developers with an interest
in helping everyone get better as we go
and you can learn more about us on our
site by the way I really made this quiz
it's a real thing I actually print it
out like a hundred copies and I have it
in my bag so you get a special
commemorative edition today if you come
up and say hi to me I'll hand you one I
also have a lot of testable stickers if
you don't want to say in person you can
actually go to test double comm / salt
and fill it out we made a Google Form
and the two of our agents yesterday
actually figure out how to automate
Google Form so it'll calculate your your
program or type and email you run away
so you know check that out too but most
importantly of all I'm really thankful
for this opportunity and for your time
this morning thank you
[Applause]